so i asked my community here on youtube
if they wanted to see a lore video on
the let me solo her player story that
has been an absolutely crazy popular
topic in the elden ring community over
the past couple of weeks while the
voting was very much in favor of making
the video some comments i received were
complacent about it melissa says are you
serious like how you'd get a text if
your girlfriend was mad at you thomas
said no
just no do you just not like this guy or
something what's up man dear nicholas
says i mean he's just a really skilled
player that's just it but if people want
it i'll support the video anyway okay
thank you i appreciate that and sean
says personally i'm more boring and just
want the juicy lore but if everyone
wants to let me solo her lore i'm all
for it lol okay so i appreciate you guys
so much on how much the channel has
grown recently it has been so much fun
making serious lore videos on elden ring
and i will not stop making those videos
i love making them there are some days
where i'll have an idea for a lore video
that i want to do and i'll search it up
on youtube just to see how many videos
have already been made on the topic and
i'll see dozens of videos multiple weeks
old already talking about the topic that
i wanted to do and it sort of
demoralizes me to actually work on it
because i feel a little bit too late to
the party i guess but the vibe i've been
getting from you all is that you
actually want to see my take on the
subject and since the lore of elden ring
is very speculative meaning nothing is
really set in stone it's all for
interpretation by the community so i
should just make the video anyway and
let me just say i really appreciate that
and i will continue to make videos even
if i feel like videos have already been
made on the subject but today we're
going to get a little bit silly with it
and go over the story of let me solo her
i think this is more community lore than
in game lore because i think the message
that this whole situation shows is
something important to the overall
experience of elden ring its community
and its gameplay and in the last video i
mentioned that 98 of people who watch my
videos are not subscribed and that got a
thousand people to subscribe overnight
and i am happy to say that only 97.7 of
you guys aren't subscribed now hey
progress is progress so thank you guys
so with all of that said let's get into
the story of let me solo her blade of
the tarnished
so unless you've been living under queen
america's booty recently you've probably
heard of the man the myth the legend
going by the name of let me solo her the
story of this guy is an extremely simple
one he died so many times apparently
over 200 times to one boss in particular
that it is now his mission in eldon ring
to help other players beat this boss so
he just puts on his cracked pot helmet
puts his summon sign down outside of the
boss room and waits for people to summon
him in and this boss is easily the
hardest boss in all of elden ring
melania blade of mikala
and i have never known defeat
well now she's known defeat over 400
times by just this legend himself let me
solo her this guy wields two katanas one
is a rivers of blood katana and the
other is just a base katana with the
horfrost stomp ash of war he also wears
no armor whatsoever besides this cracked
pot on his head and i guess if you don't
plan on getting hit by the boss what's
the point of wearing really any armor
now if you didn't know melania has a ton
of health she can also get health back
just by landing attacks on the player
she also has two phases where in the
second phase she turns into the rot
queen and starts doing rot damage with
pretty much the exact same moveset as
the first phase with the addition of
this scarlet rot aoe attack she already
does a ton of damage with most of her
attacks she's extremely fast and can
make up ground on the player in a blink
of an eye and on top of all of that she
has an ash war attack that most of the
elden ring community is calling complete
total [ __ ] it's called the waterfowl
dance where she rapidly swings her sword
around for what seems like forever
quickly narrowing the gap between
yourself and the player and if the
player is too close when she decides to
start using it there is little to no
chance of surviving the attack so
basically what i'm trying to get here is
that if you mess up you are going to die
needless to say
it's very hard so the legend himself is
going into this fight with no armor or
really any type of exploit to make this
fight easier for him he is defeating
melania based only on his pure skill to
dodge her attacks and punish her at the
right moments he is the epitome of the
get good concept that the souls game
community is so big on and what i mean
by that is that if you don't beat the
boss like let me solo her does then the
community has a tendency to be little
players for using resources other than
their own skill to beat a boss that goes
for any boss in the game like if you use
summons bleed weapons ranged attacks are
a sorcerer used any type of ash of war
upgraded your weapon leveled your
character at all turned on your monitor
used a controller or turned on
the electricity people will tell you
that you didn't actually beat the boss
now listen no matter what i say here it
will be met with people arguing about
whether this is right or wrong to do but
what i think we can all agree on is that
if you actively belittle players for
playing the game the way that they want
to play it then you're just a [ __ ]
loser with way too much time on their
hands like you need to calm down just
because a player does not beat every
boss in the game by bashing their head
into a wall for hours on in to never be
hit by any boss take any damage or
whatever it is doesn't make their play
through or their boss fight any less
legitimate you are just trying to have a
superiority complex over another player
because you beat a boss in a harder way
and it's kind of sad
gate keeping a mainly single player game
like are you okay do you really not have
anything better to do there's plenty of
amazing players out there who do these
difficult challenge runs but also don't
shove it in other people's faces it's
like that kid in school who will ask all
the other kids in the class what they
got on a test because they know they got
the hundred percent and probably did
better than them i believe those kids
were always known as
annoying the souls game community has a
pretty bad reputation for doing exactly
this so i wish people would just stop
doing it but i don't think that's
possible unfortunately so why am i
talking about all this in a let me solo
her video because this is the exact
opposite experience of what all of the
gatekeeping players want while also
having a single guy out there doing that
exact experience that they try to gate
keep on to people and i find that
hilarious this guy is basically telling
people to not play the game saying i got
this don't even try just sit back relax
and watch a master go to work and i love
it based on what i've seen most people
are loving it too in a community where
the only help people usually get is
someone saying get good there's this guy
who goes against the hardest boss in the
game and beats this boss for people like
it's his job he even has a schedule
where he's usually there between 3 to 8
pm cst i found a message on reddit that
says he feels bad when he messes up and
fails he says sometimes the lag between
the host and myself is too much and i
get killed instantly or miss the crucial
dodge timing on melania's waterfowl
dance i would like to express my apology
to those i have failed like what a nice
guy man he's just trying to help others
and in a gaming community that's really
rare to see whitney houston music
intensifies that's hilarious dude i love
it here man so hopefully this inspires
people to go out there and help more
players because more than likely the
number one reason players stop playing
the game is likely because they get
stuck on a boss they get frustrated and
they quit eldon rang and all of the
souls games are about overcoming
adversity and persistence but it's okay
to ask for help when you're struggling
you don't have to become the omega
gigachad in skill just to beat this game
and i don't think it ruins the
experience for the player to get help i
truly don't the first time i beat the
fire giant i used a glitch that made him
fall off a cliff and instantly killed
him i posted it on tiktok which is
usually just the garbage can of comment
sections and had a ton of people saying
how could someone have fun doing
something like this i remember a time
where glitches were awesome like they'd
get millions of views on youtube of
everyone praising like oh my god great
job finding this glitch dude i can't
wait to go home from school and use it
myself i guess that's just not a thing
in gaming anymore like i see most people
complaining about glitches and as you
can see in this clip i am laughing my
ass off and having a great time now i've
gone back and killed him legitimately
multiple times now but that first
experience where i used an exploit to
beat him did not ruin my experience i
had fun doing it in my own way and
trying to gatekeep that is such loser
[ __ ] energy so you know what thank
you let me solo her i think you're a
true legend in the elden ring community
and you should keep doing what you're
doing you've been an inspiration to me
to get better get more skilled and go
out there and help players who may be
struggling at the game where it's
usually a very lonely experience i know
there wasn't a lot of lore in this video
but i just love the story of this guy it
fills my heart and it makes me happy so
i wanted to talk about it thank you all
for watching this video again make sure
to hit the subscribe button so that we
can get that percentage a little bit
higher i still cry myself to sleep at
night knowing that there's only about
two percent of people that are actually
subscribed and watch my videos but i
also cry and happiness because of all
the support i i truly do really
appreciate it thank you i'll see you all
in the next video take care guys
[Music]
you